Maya: Today our guest is Kelly McGonigal.
She is an expert in body/mind relationship
and psychology of yoga.
So, she's teaching yoga and psychology -- meditation
-- at Stanford.
And today, she's here with us to talk about
how to use yoga for pain relief.
So, let's welcome Kelly.
[applause]
Kelly McGonigal: Thanks, Maya. Thanks, Cliff.
As Maya mentioned, I'm a health psychologist
and a yoga teacher, and I work a lot with
people who have chronic pain issues.
But not a lot of people know about my own
experience with chronic pain.
And one of the most interesting things that
has come about from writing this book is that
-- [video skips] -- I do have chronic pain
and that I have a headache just about every
day of my life from the last 20 years.
And the people in my life seem very kind of
perplexed by this.
They say things like, "But it doesn't seem
to be impacting your life." -- [video skips]
-- and it doesn't seem to limit my life.
-- [video skips] -- Students come up to me
and test me in class like, [in a whisper]
"Are you in pain right now?"
And if I say, "Yes," like, [whispering] "You
have a headache right now?
Wow!"
Because, of course, we have this idea that
pain comes with suffering.
And in my experience -- through yoga and meditation
-- it's possible to have pain not completely
go away, but to feel like you have your life
back again.
And sometimes, the pain does go away, even
if you never knew what was causing the pain
and nothing else seemed to work.
And this is kind of part of the mystery of
chronic pain -- that sometimes it doesn't
go away and life gets better anyway, and sometimes
it does go away through things that you never
thought might be the solution to healing your
pain.
And so, I'm here today to talk to you about
how yoga can be this kind of miracle worker,
creating unexpected healing where nothing
else seems to work for pain.
Because most people who come to yoga for pain
relief have tried everything else; they've
tried surgeries, shots, medications, acupuncture,
massage, maybe a $600 office chair -- you
name it.
'Cause when we think about heavy-hitting medical
interventions, we don't tend to think of yoga
as being sort of the first place to go.
You know -- yoga, all that stretching, ohming,
lying around and breathing -- maybe that'll
take the edge off the pain if you chase it
with a Percocet, but it really, like how is
that going to help?
And, you know, sort of joking aside, there's
a growing body of scientific evidence that
yoga can provide profound relief for many
different types of chronic pain -- whether
it's chronic back pain, joint pain, autoimmune
disorders, fibromyalgia, chronic fatigue syndrome,
headaches, IBS, you name it -- if it's a chronic
pain, there's probably a study showing that
yoga helps and that yoga helps better than
traditional medical care.
And you may not have one of these particular
chronic pain conditions, but we all have chronic
stress, and we all have this sort of chronic,
ordinary suffering of being a human being
in a world that's sometimes difficult and
in a body that sometimes does not seem to
cooperate.
And yoga helps with all of that too.
So, I hope that you'll hear something today
that is useful, whether or not you have chronic
pain.
So, what I want to do today is talk a little
bit about yoga -- give you some of the latest
insights from mind/body science that's changed
the way medicine thinks about chronic pain
and gives us a sense of why yoga might be
so helpful for chronic pain as well as some
of the coolest findings on yoga therapy for
pain.
And then, we'll take some questions and do
a little practice.
So, for those of you who would like to stay,
we'll do a practice that incorporates some
of the most gentle yoga meditation techniques.
You don't need yoga clothes.
You don't need a yoga mat, which is good,
because it doesn't look like anyone brought
one.
So, if you'd like to stay for that, you already
have everything that you need.
So, one thing I want to just start off with
is that, when I say "yoga," I'm not talking
about sort of, you know, "power yoga" or just
the movement component.
I'm talking about five different sets of practices
from the yoga tradition.
There's the movement -- the exercise component
-- but there's also breathing and meditation
and relaxation and what I call "befriending
the body" or the practices of self-care and
of making friends and making peace with your
body even if you have illness or injury.
And, definitely not talking about circus yoga.
So, you don't need to be able to stand on
your head or put your leg behind your head
or anything else that would qualify you to
be on a yoga magazine cover.
This is really basic stuff, and there's always
a place to start.
If you can breathe, you can do yoga.
If you have a body, you can do yoga.
And one of the things that I try to do in
the book was provide a true starting place,
even for people who've never done yoga before,
and even for people who have some pretty serious,
physical limitations.
Okay. So, I think I'll start by sharing these
three key ideas that come out of mind/body
science that's really changed the way people
think about chronic pain.
It may change the way that you think about
your own pain and your own stress.
And the first is the recognition that pain
is a protective and instinctive mind/body
response.
From Mother Nature's perspective, it's not
a problem.
Pain is not a problem. It's actually a solution
-- a clever solution of evolution -- to make
you care about whether or not your body is
harmed.
It's a nice little trick to make sure that
you stay alive and that you're motivated to
keep yourself away from physical danger.
And it starts -- the full mind/body response
starts -- any time there is a threat to your
body.
It could be someone punching you in the face
or it could be pulling a muscle from an activity
or touching a hot stove.
And you've got receptors in your skin, your
muscles, your joints, and your organs that
live for this moment -- that have been waiting
for some kind of threat so that they can do
their jobs -- send a message up to the brain.
And that's just the beginning of the pain
process.
So once your pain receptors have identified
that "not everything is okay in the world"
-- that there is this threat to your body,
to your safety -- that message gets sent to
the brain, and not just the area to the brain
that many of us think of as being important
for pain.
So yes, that message is going to be sent to
the sensory areas of the brain so that you
have a physical sense that you are a little
bit in trouble.
But, it also gets sent to the emotional areas
of the brain that are going to make you "not
happy" about the fact that you are in pain.
And this is why, when we experience physical
pain, we start to feel anxious, we start to
feel angry and feel a lot of distress.
And that signal also gets sent to the areas
of the brain that control your attention and
that monitor for conflict and whether or not
you've met your goals yet.
And so, when the signal gets to these areas
of the brain, it becomes very hard to focus
on anything else, except for the pain and
the emotions around the pain.
So now, your mind is going to be highly focused
on solving this problem -- whatever is threatening
your safety.
And when the mind is focused in this way,
it prompts the body into a physiological stress
response, so that you have the energy to handle
whatever the threat is.
So we've got a brain that's completely consumed
now with the process of pain -- your attention,
your emotions, and your sensation -- and the
body is going to shift into a state of stress
to help you deal with it to solve the problem.
And you can imagine how -- from an evolutionary
perspective -- this is really useful, because
it will allow you to protect yourself.
But, you know, if this is repetitive -- if
this is chronic -- this is really not a great
way to live.
And the last part of the protective pain,
mind/body response is something that most
of us don't even realize is part of this biological
pain response.
And that's the process of learning from injury
or from pain.
You may have noticed the last time you experienced
a lot of pain, it was kind of sticky in your
mind.
You kept thinking about it or maybe you wanted
to tell the story to somebody else.
And that's a really common response to pain.
The mind -- the brain -- is trying to grapple
with what happened so that it can learn from
it and avoid that pain in the future.
But it means that we get very stuck on our
painful experiences, and we may become even
more vigilant for any evidence of threat or
pain in the body.
And at the level of the nervous system, your
body and your brain are also trying to adapt
in a way that's going to make it easier to
respond to the same danger or threat in the
future.
So, for example, if you've had a back injury,
the nerves of the spine and of the back are
going to actually get better at listening
to signs of pressure or inflammation or damage
to the connective tissue or to the muscles.
Literally, those pain receptors are going
to get better at listening for it.
And they're going to be more eager to send
a signal of pain to your brain so that you
will be able to respond more quickly.
And this way, we have a back now that is sensitized
to pain.
And this learning process happens pretty much
with any injury or with any illness where
the body is prepared to experience that pain
again.
And you can kind of think of this as being
like backwards from the immune system.
If you get a cold, you're less likely to get
that same cold again.
Or if you have a flu type, you're less likely
to get that again.
But with pain, once you've had a certain type
of pain, you're actually more likely to experience
it again because of the way that the body
and the brain adapts to a pain experience.
And then, this level of learning from our
pain shows up in one last way, which is that,
we may try to avoid things that could re-create
this pain.
And for people who've had very painful experience
-- like an accident or an injury or a serious
illness -- they may start to limit their lives
so that they're not exposed to as many dangerous
things.
And this can have a self-perpetuating cycle
where, the more we fear pain, the less we're
willing to do, and our lives get smaller and
smaller.
That was my experience for awhile also.
Okay, so this first big idea is that -- thanks
to evolution -- we have an instinctive and
protective mind/body response that helps us
deal with real threat.
And even though it can be annoying, it's useful.
But the second key idea to come out of research
in the last decade is that, chronic pain doesn't
work like acute pain.
It is not useful in the way that an acute
pain process is.
Chronic pain is overprotective and learned,
not protective and instinctive.
People who have chronic pain have a body and
a brain that have learned to be oversensitive
to a particular type of pain or a part of
the pain process, because it has learned so
well from whatever the initial injury or illness
or accident or traumatic event was.
And there's a lot of different ways that people
with chronic pain may have learned this sort
of over-responsiveness.
I mentioned one, which is the sensitization
of nerves.
That is, once you have an injury and illness,
many times, part of the healing process is
making the nervous system more likely to think
that you are in pain.
And for some people, it goes as far as having
ordinary, safe sensations being strongly interpreted
by the nervous system and by the brain as
being "dangerous, unsafe, and painful."
And a classic example of that is someone who
has back pain or maybe an old shoulder injury
or knee injury where they start to exercise
again.
And the body interprets the very normal, safe
-- even healing -- movements of a gentle
exercise practice as being painful and damaging.
And that's a real experience.
The pain is not somehow in your mind.
It's real -- and it is physiological, but
it's no longer realistic.
It has nothing to do with actual harm that's
being created in your body.
And this is a really key insight if you have
chronic pain that it's almost as if the body
and the brain are lying to you about what
is safe and the state of your body and the
state of your health.
And when the body has learned to be oversensitive
in this way -- sort of over-learned from the
experience of pain -- it's really important
to unlearn this process, and that's where
yoga and meditation comes in.
It's a process of re-education.
The last key idea that's come from the pain
research, which is the one that people tend
to resist the most, because it sounds -- well,
it sounds both kind of discouraging and also
almost -- people have heard for so long that
"your pain is all in your mind" or "your pain
is just psychological," that we can be a little
resistant to hearing that, "When you have
chronic pain, emotional pain is not distinct
from physical pain."
This is not true for all types of pain, but
for most people with chronic pain, the brain
and the nervous system have stopped distinguishing
between stress, anxiety, depression, grief,
anger, and something going wrong in the body
that we need to be concerned with.
One of my favorite examples comes from research
showing that, people who have chronic back
pain -- when they get angry -- their back
muscles tense up, and there's inflammation
in the tissues of the back.
And that only happens for people who have
chronic back pain.
It's like the nervous system has associated
so many times anger and stress with that biological
process, that it's no longer that part of
the body triggering a stress response, but
the stress response or the emotion actually
triggers that reaction in the body.
Kind of in the same way that if you were to
remember a -- don't do this now -- but if
you were to remember a great sexual moment
in your life, you could trigger some very
real changes in your body, yes? It is possible.
It turns out that chronic pain works a lot
like that too.
And there's been some interesting research
at Stanford showing that, even just the memory
of pain can re-create changes in the body
that are consistent with that pain -- like
muscle tension, like inflammation, like an
increased stress response.
And, in addition, one of the things I didn't
mention is that, the protective pain response
that I described -- the one that is useful
for us in most situations -- it's the same
for a physical threat as for a social threat.
That is, the same areas of the brain are recruited,
including physical sensations of pain.
If you have been punched in the jaw or if
you've been rejected by a loved one, when
you're feeling lonely, you've got pretty much
the same process going on -- same regions
of the brain activated -- as when you have
the flu.
And that's one of the reasons why heartbreak
really, really hurts.
We're being rejected or when you're feeling
angry at someone -- it actually hurts.
And you can imagine, from an evolutionary
perspective, why that might be useful too.
Because when we think about what threatens
our well-being, being separated from the tribe
is one of the most dangerous, dangerous things
that could happen for your well-being and
for your life.
And so, it seems like evolution has kind of
mapped these two together.
So that when you are in emotional pain or
particularly social pain, you're going to
use the same systems that help protect you
when there's a physical threat.
Again, this gets very tricky with chronic
pain, because it means that the emotions related
to social relationships -- stress at work,
all of that -- it can reinforce the pain.
And, in fact, for people who have chronic
pain, there's evidence that psychological
stress even further sensitizes the nervous
system to send those threat signals up to
the brain.
So, when you're stressed or when you're angry
or when you're lonely, it's like the whole
nervous system is listening for more evidence
that something is wrong.
And what all of this means is that, if you
have chronic pain, stress management is number
one on the agenda for healing pain.
And even though it sounds kind of "woo woo"
or fuzzy, handling stress and emotions tends
to be a lot more effective for chronic pain
than trying to find one thing in the body
that's wrong and fixing it with surgery or
medications.
Because with chronic pain, that one thing
that's wrong in the body,
that was resolved or healed probably a long
time ago, and what you're left with is this
kind of residual learning that is systemic.
It's in the whole body, including the embodied
mind -- the nervous system, the brain.
It's no longer just in your back muscle or
just in your knee or just in your jaw or wherever
the pain originated.
So, I think that might be fun to share with
you some of the findings.
Some of you know that I'm a yoga researcher,
and I think it's really exciting how much
research is being done on yoga these days.
I want to share with you some of the findings
that might either give you a little more motivation
to do yoga, or that -- for those of you who
are already yoga enthusiasts -- you might
be able to marshal some of this evidence against
the people who are resisting yoga who might
benefit from it.
I've heard that you shouldn't drag people
to yoga, but I think sometimes data can drag
people to yoga, which is useful.
So there have been a number of studies in
the last couple of years showing that yoga
is more effective for chronic back pain than
regular exercise or standard medical care.
And that a very gentle yoga practice done
a couple times a week for about 30 minutes
a day -- some very gentle moving, breathing,
and relaxation -- actually helps people reduce
their need for pain medications, including
very strong pain medications like opiates.
As well as improving the symptoms -- the psychological
symptoms of chronic pain, like depression
-- as well as the physical function and the
physical pain.
And other studies have shown that yoga can
really change the way that the nervous system
responds to stress.
There's a study that just came out looking
at restorative yoga.
And this is a really easy way into yoga.
Restorative yoga -- you basically lie around
in a bunch of different positions, hugging
pillows and breathing.
And this study showed that people who practiced
restorative yoga have lower baseline levels
of inflammation.
And this is really key, because inflammation
-- circulating levels of inflammation in
your body -- prime you to experience pain.
They sensitize the nerves so you're more likely
to experience pain and discomfort and swelling
and all of that.
And not only do they have lower baseline levels
of inflammation, but when the researchers
expose them to a stressful situation, they
have less of an inflammatory response to that
stress.
So things were good from the get-go.
And when you stress them out, that stress
response doesn't look so unhealthy.
It certainly doesn't look like the kind of
stress response that really reinforces and
makes pain worse.
Another key study that came out recently was
looking at people who have an autoimmune disorder,
which tends to be characterized by high levels
of stress response in the body -- sympathetic
nervous system activation.
And they found that a short yoga program actually
reduced baseline levels of sympathetic nervous
system activity in a population where that
can be one of the key factors in determining
whether you have a good day, a bad day, a
good week, a bad week -- whether you can get
out of bed or not.
And again, there's a really simple practice,
but one that included a little bit of breathing,
a little bit of relaxation, a little bit of
movement.
And then, there are all the studies looking
at meditation as a kind of a special form
of yoga -- a special -- this sort of unique
way to deal with pain, by teaching you how
to choose the focus of your attention and
also how not to panic when you feel pain or
a distressful emotion.
And there have been studies looking at -- you
may think of as kind of "meditation masters"
-- people who've been doing it for a long
time.
And in these studies, they exposed the meditators
to some pretty serious pain, maybe thermal
stimulation, a point where this is not subjective
whether this hurts -- there's some real tissue
damage happening; this hurts.
And they looked at what happens in the brain
of the meditator when they're being exposed
to this subjective, painful stimulation.
And meditators appear to be able to literally
shut down parts of the pain processing, particularly
the emotional aspect of pain processing that
makes you feel like there's something really,
really terrible about what's happening in
your body.
And I started this talk by mentioning that
I have a headache almost every day, and yet,
I don't really have any suffering.
It's just kind of there.
And I think that's a big part of what's going
on with some of these meditators that you
can be receiving part of the pain signal,
and yet, it doesn't launch this full, overprotective,
learned response of the brain freaking out
and the body freaking out and having to solve
it as a problem.
There's even a study published a couple months
ago that took people who weren't expert meditators,
introduced them to mindfulness meditation
and a little bit of gentle yoga movement and
relaxation.
And before and after this intervention, they
took pictures -- 3-dimensional pictures -- of
the brain.
And they were particularly interested in the
areas of the brain that detect threat and
produce the stress response.
And they found that, after this 8-week intervention,
the participants actually had decreased neuronal
density in the regions of the brain that interpret
threat and produce a stress response.
It is in a way like the brain was getting
smaller.
And this is one of the first studies that's
been able to show this, even though there
are lots of studies showing that chronic pain
and chronic stress makes this area of the
brain bigger and more connected to other areas
of the brain.
And so, this is the first study showing that
gentle yoga and meditation can reverse that
process and essentially create a brain that's
more resilient to stress and less likely to
produce this overprotective stress response.
There's lots of other studies like this, including
studies that aren't directly connected to
yoga and meditation, but show that shifting
your focus of attention or improving your
mood can have the equivalent effect on pain
as a dose of morphine.
And this is what yoga practice is all about
-- choosing the focus of your attention and
boosting your mood a little bit.
I guess the last finding that there's anyone
left unconvinced is, the most recent observation
that meditation and gentle movement like yoga
increases neuroplasticity.
I'd mentioned that chronic pain is a learned
response.
And the solution for most people with chronic
pain is not something like surgery, but the
re-education process -- the re-learning.
And meditation and gentle movement increase
brain-derived neurotrophic factor, which is
what allows the brain to actually learn new
habits.
And you can actually take a brain that has
trained itself to over-interpret stress and
pain and become much more resilient and less
reactive.
And I think at this point, it might be useful
to open it up to some questions about yoga
or pain or anything.
Now, we're going to -- did you want to use
one of the other microphones for this or this
one?
Q Thanks. [pause]
A Hi.
Q Hi. So my question is, you were talking
about the body kind of remembering an old
injury and being more susceptible or, you
know, triggering pain more than it would if
it didn't have that.
Is it site specific, meaning like, if I had
one bad knee injury a long time ago, is my
entire body more sensitive to pain, or is
it just to that one spot?
A It's a great question.
Should I repeat it, or is that microphone
going to pick up?
Great. Yeah -- so, it depends. It's definitely
not all bad news.
Probably the knee will be more likely to experience
pain and discomfort, and it doesn't necessarily
translate to the whole body.
For some people, it does.
And that happens more at the higher level
of the nervous system rather than the nerves
down at the joint or any scar tissue around
the joint.
And so, it could be possible for a site-specific
injury to translate into a more general sensitivity
to pain.
It's not usually how it works.
Most of us will have a more specific vulnerability,
like back pain or knee pain or like with myself
with headaches.
But there are folks for whom it becomes systemic.
Q Hello?
A Hi.
Q Hi, Kelly. Question from -- oh. [Pause]
Hey, question from Crittendon -- "I have a
friend -- or three or four actually -- who
I think should hear this talk.
Do you have any public events where you'll
be giving a similar talk scheduled in the
area in the future?
Or is there a place where I can learn about
those if they should come up?"
A Yes, where is this question coming from?
I don't even know where to look.
Should I look in the camera?
Q [laughing] You can just look at the camera.
I can see you. Sorry -- that's a little spooky.
A That's a very kind question.
I like those softball questions.
I hear that this talk will be available on
YouTube.
I do have some public events coming up.
You can see my website for that.
I have some talks at local libraries, JCC
Center.
That's at KellyMcGonigal.com.
And I teach a class at Stanford through Continuing
Studies called "The Science of Meditation:
The Science of a Calmed Mind."
That's all about how these practices, including
yoga, change the brain, change the body.
And so, for people who need that kind of academic,
scientific nudge to adopt this practice, that
class is a really good entryway, because there
are enormous piles of data in that class.
Q Thank you.
A You're welcome.
Q So, I'm reading this really interesting
book.
It's by John Sarno, called "The MindBody Prescription."
A Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Q You probably read it already.
So, for those of you who don't know, his whole
theory is that your pain is blocking some
deep emotional feeling, and it's like a distraction
from that feeling.
I was wondering what you thought of his thesis?
A You know, so -- I'm not familiar with his
work very personally, but I actually had a
student who claims to have been completely
cured through one of his lectures.
John Sarno's idea -- this idea that most people's
chronic pain is a symptom of some sort of
distressed emotion and that just knowing that
your pain is not something wrong with your
body, but that it's related to emotions and
stress.
His idea is that -- just knowing that -- cures
the pain.
Kind of an education process of just kind
of cognitive insight.
And once you have that "aha" moment, the whole
pain changes.
So, anecdotally, I know one person who says
that that's true.
As someone who's very interested in the mechanisms,
I like to know a little bit more.
But in terms of what might be happening in
the brain, why an emotion that you either
experience or are trying to avoid might trigger
a pain response.
I think that the -- I think the science is
not inconsistent with the hypothesis that
emotions can trigger chronic pain.
But I think that most of the evidence suggests
that there was a physical start as well.
So it's not going to be completely random.
Like, you never had a back injury or any issues
around the back, but suddenly, anger is going
to create back pain.
I think it's useful to think about all of
us as having physical vulnerabilities that
chronic stress and emotions will latch on
to.
But I like his idea that dealing with the
emotions is a good place to start.
Yes. Oh, oh sorry.
Did we -- where is this mic going?
Q You talk about different -- I guess -- modalities.
I'm not sure quite what the word is -- things
that you do to get this -- breathing, the
movement, the meditation, all this.
Can you break that down a little bit, I guess?
I mean, like if I had only a few minutes to
do one, which one should I do?
A It depends. It's a great question.
When I mentioned "five modalities" -- you
got to breathe, you got to meditate, relax,
exercise, take care of yourself -- that can
sound like a 3-hour project, which nobody
has time for.
And so, the question of "What do you do if
you only have one minute?"
I think it's different for different people.
And when I work with students one-on-one,
it's kind of an exploration process to figure
out what's going to be the one yoga ritual
that most makes you feel safe in your body
and in your mind.
I think that's the -- sort of the starting
question point, because chronic pain is the
experience of the body and brain not feeling
safe.
And so, for some people it may be relaxation.
For some people, there may be a specific movement
or stretch that makes their body feel really
good and cared for.
For some people, mindfulness meditation works
really well.
Just sitting down, being with the breath.
And it could be other things as well.
So, in the book, I lay out lots of options.
And I encourage people to go to what they
feel drawn to.
And as soon as you hear about it or read it
and you think, "Well, that sounds kind of
appealing, not painful, not difficult -- might
improve something about my state of mind or
body."
And when you find something that works, to
stick with it.
So I mentioned that a lot of the studies that
look at yoga for pain relief use all of these
modalities.
And I'm not suggesting that you have to do
all of them in order to feel the relief, but
I think in the group setting -- in a clinical
setting -- you need to offer all of them,
because people will respond to different techniques
and different practices.
But you yourself may find that it's sitting
in meditation for a few minutes or that it's
a joint mobilization sequence.
So I can't tell you exactly what to start
with.
But I would say to start with where you're
naturally drawn.
Q Hi. So you talk about this secondary pain
response where the injured part is not necessarily
being damaged anymore but our brain is kind
of tricking us by sending the pain signal.
A Mm-hmm.
Q And so, my question is, how do you recognize
that that's the case, that that's happening,
because it seems like -- to the brain it seems
like the same kind of pain.
A Yeah, it's real.
And, of course, pain only happens in the brain.
I mean, one of the things I want to be really
clear about is that this pain in the brain
is real.
There's no other type of pain.
And it doesn't matter whether it was generated
by someone punching you or something you can
observe that's wrong with the body or whether
it started in the brain.
It's just as real and just as painful.
You know, the way that most people start to
realize that it's not about something that's
objectively wrong in the body anymore is by
going through every test under the book and
trying surgery and finding that that doesn't
work.
I mean, it's almost a trial and error, because
many times, when people are in pain, there
is a physical problem.
It could be cancer; it could be a joint issue
that could be repaired.
And chronic pain is different than most of
those situations, because chronic pain is
persistent and usually unexplainable.
And it's only -- you know, the mechanisms
that I'm describing by which pain becomes
chronic -- it's not like doctors have good
ways of diagnosing that.
A lot of that comes from animal research where,
you know, they can really look at what's going
on in the nervous system.
And so, there's not a great way for your doctor
to look at you and say, "Hey, that pain is
starting in your brain."
Although, there are some researchers who are
using real-time brain imaging to help show
patients how their pain is being created in
the brain.
But that's not yet a clinical technique, so
that wouldn't be useful for you.
But I would say that, if you have been exploring
-- through standard physical care -- the
source of your pain, and nobody can find anything
-- and that's what happens for a lot of people
-- that's when exploring these other aspects
like yoga and meditation may end up holding
the key.
Q And so, when you recognize that that's the
case, what do you then do, because if your
injured part is not hurting anymore per se.
A Yeah. Yeah.
Q The response probably should be different.
A Right. And you start by retraining the response.
So, for example, breathing is a technique
that changes the physiology of the body and
the brain pretty quickly.
You can breathe in a way that's going to shut
down the stress response, lower inflammation.
You can breathe in a way that's going to calm
down the emotional centers of the brain.
And that's the essential training process
of yoga and meditation is, you work with the
response and you practice a new response.
And you don't work with -- necessarily -- the
area of the body that feels like it's in pain.
Most people, when they hear that I wrote a
book about yoga for pain relief, they're like,
"Where's the chapter on neck pain?
Where are the neck stretches for neck pain?
Where are the back stretches for back pain?"
And that does not work with chronic pain,
because you can't fix a nervous system problem
by just stretching out that part of the body.
And so, personally, I think that's good news,
because it means, even if you don't know what's
causing your pain, you can start with the
same basic practices of relaxation, simple
breath focus, and mindful movement of whatever
part of your body can move without pain.
So I don't know if that's of any use.
Q Yes, thank you.
Q You know, yoga is a science, and it's got
many different branches.
So I've been thinking of getting into yoga
and meditation for quite some time.
And every time I kind of gotten to looking
at what I should be doing, I come up with
various forms of yoga, like Kundalini and
Hatha and Astina and power yoga and then there
are different forms of meditation.
And you know like Kundalini yoga says that,
if you have back problem, you should not be
doing this.
So, you know, how do you really get started
just as a basic person without getting to
know that, you know, if I meditate.
Because somewhere I read that it takes you
years before you can even reach to that one
second of meditative state where you do not
have 500 thoughts crossing your mind in a
second.
So, it's kind of, you know, demotivating as
well why you want to do it but then you just
get confused by all that information that's
out there.
So, how do you just get started without -- you
know?
A Yeah. I can actually give a very specific
answer to that, and then, I'll give a more
general response.
I actually almost always send people first
to mindfulness-based stress reduction programs.
Some of you may have taken that.
It's an 8-week course where you learn how
to focus on your breath.
You learn the relaxation technique.
You learn very gentle yoga movements that
are safe for most people.
And you learn some of the ideas of yoga philosophy
and how they relate to everyday life.
And even though it tends to be considered
a meditation training, because it involves
movement and breathing and relaxation and
yoga philosophy, it's like the perfect introduction
to yoga.
And I know they offer NBSR all over the Bay
Area -- I think, probably even offer it here.
Does Google have --?
Q They're starting next week.
A It's starting next week?
Q Yep. Yep.
A There -- I think so.
I actually think that's going to be a really
great introduction.
And they will, I think, quickly disabuse you
of the notion that it's going to take millions
of years to achieve meditation.
You know, with meditation, you don't even
need to empty the mind or clear your thoughts.
You can just -- you can have one moment of
breath focus in a 10-minute meditation, and
that in itself can be healing.
So, you can get benefit much sooner than it
takes to become a monk.
And the other thing that I'll say is that,
one of the most encouraging things about the
research on yoga for pain is that they're
almost always looking at people who had no
yoga or meditation experience and saw these
-- not just statistically significant, but
clinically significant -- improvements in
8 weeks.
These aren't very long interventions.
And so, you know, I think that there's hope.
Q Thanks.
Q Just adding to this discussion that was
happening.
I am a yoga teacher, and I've had an experience
of teaching yoga back in India, practicing
yoga there and practicing yoga here.
And I have found a very big difference in
the U.S. -- the way you always talk about
yoga and meditation together.
In the U.S., there is this whole big thing
of looking at yoga as another form of exercise.
It's like, you know, power yoga -- and I think
some of the injuries are created here, because
there is so much of emphasis on totally the
physical part -- looking it as just like another
form of exercise.
And the way to enter yoga is to understand
it holistically -- body, mind, breath.
Like the way you said, the meditation part
is not to be neglected.
The philosophy is not to be neglected.
And only then, yoga provides this healing
process, the whole.
It's innate in it, you know?
But I feel that it's kind of neglected here.
But the perspective in India is totally different
from it.
A Yeah, and that's really the traditional
perspective.
And thank God most of the studies are actually
looking at the traditional yoga rather than
super fit "yoga butt" yoga.
And that's not where I would send someone
initially.
Although physical exercise is really, really
important, but sometimes yoga classes that
are presenting yoga as a hard-core workout
really lose the elements of relaxation and
breathing that make it so healing for chronic
pain.
So, exercise is important, but I definitely
would not start with any form of yoga that
was advertising itself primarily as a workout.
You would miss a lot and possibly hurt yourself.
Q Can you comment on the connection between
yoga and diet?
A Yoga and diet -- yes.
Well, in the yoga tradition, what you eat
is considered both a reflection of your willingness
to care for your own body and an expression
of your values.
So, you know, within the yoga tradition, it's
common to eat the kind of diet that Michael
Pollan might approve of -- mostly plants and
real food and not a whole lot of it or whatever
his -- what are his rules?
Says, you know, mostly -- eat mostly plants
and fruits and vegetables.
Don't eat too much.
I think that that's the essential yoga diet.
And there's some good evidence that eating
a mostly plant-based diet, possibly a vegetarian
diet, changes the way that the body responds
to stress, improving things like heart rate
variability and inflammation.
That could be really important for chronic
pain and chronic stress.
Now, I'm personally a vegan.
So I always feel like I'm proselytizing a
little bit when I say that.
So, let me just say that, you can go much
more broad than that and not worry about the
traditional diet and just think of -- starting
to pay attention to how "what you eat" influences
your energy, how it influences your mood,
how it even influences your pain.
Because many people will find that they have
triggers -- food triggers -- for being in
a bad mood.
Not what you eat when you are in a bad mood,
but food that actually puts you in a worse
mood -- makes you feel worse about yourself,
it makes your body feel sluggish and tired.
And so, yeah, you know -- without any sort
of moral judgments about what you might eat,
there's this basic practice of starting to
pay attention to how food influences you and
a willingness to take care of yourself by
eating what makes you feel healthier and stronger.
Q How about yoga and other form of exercises,
you know?
If I practice yoga, is there other form of
exercise that are more compatible or they
are not compatible?
Any concern about that?
A Yeah. So, the question is, "Are there other
forms of exercise that are more or less compatible
with yoga?"
And, I think, the way that I would express
it is that, once you learn how to move skillfully
and honor your body in yoga, it's going to
improve your experience in any other form
of exercise -- whether it's weight lifting
or swimming or dancing.
And so, I would say more that, learning how
to listen to your body through yoga, to not
push yourself beyond what seems like a reasonable
limit, to listen to the signals of your body
about fatigue and stretch and pain, and a
kind of willingness to stay in the process
mentally.
All of that is going to make other forms of
exercise not just more fun, but a lot safer.
So if you learn how to do those things in
yoga, you're going to be much less likely
to hurt yourself if you go to an aerobics
class or play a sport.
And I have a number of students who are athletes
who kind of use their yoga practice in that
way as a kind of baseline so that when they
go out and do other things, they're less likely
to hurt themselves.
In terms of the physical benefits, yoga is
not cardiovascular.
So if you are thinking about your health,
the only way to get a really strong cardiovascular
workout from yoga is to do it wrong.
To, you know -- to not breathe in a slow and
sustained way.
Because, even if you're doing things that
are a little bit physically difficult, if
you're breathing in the yoga way, you're not
going to get your heart rate that high.
There's plenty of studies showing that.
So, it's nice to balance yoga with other forms
of exercise that are appropriate for your
body that would take care of that other stuff.
>> All right. Well, I think that wraps up
our questions.
So, thank you very much.
It was an outstanding talk.
Thank you.
A Thanks.
[Applause]
>> Kelly: So, I see we have about 15 minutes
left.
Do you want to do a little bit of a practice?
Yes?
I'd thought that we would do some movement,
some breathing, some relaxation, and meditation.
It's kind of an unusual spot to lie down on
the ground and meditate.
So, let's start with movement and that may
be -- movement and breathing -- and that may
be as far as we get.
I'm going to -- [pause] Yeah, so I'll use
this mic.
And we're going to start in a chair -- how
convenient.
But I want you to have a little more space
for yourself.
So, these chairs move. You can move your chair.
Maybe come -- those of you who are sandwiched
in a row, there's a lot of room up front,
a lot of chairs up front -- you could come
up here.
This is going to be interesting to demonstrate
and hold this at the same time.
Oh, that's right. That's what the stand is
for. [pause]
I feel like I'm on "American Idol." [pause]
Is that going to be about the right, no -- is
that about the right sound volume?
Okay, so we're going to be efficient with
this and move and breathe at the same time.
You were probably already breathing, but you
might not have noticed.
So we're going to breathe with some intention
here.
And some of the key ideas about yoga movement
and breathing is, first of all, it should
feel better -- not worse -- than if you were
not doing it.
So, as soon as something feels obviously worse
than before you started, come out of it.
There may be a way to come back into it with
a little bit less strain.
You know, sort of relax a little bit in it.
Or it may be that this is not the movement
or stretch for you in this moment and be willing
to honor that.
The other key principle is that, we join the
movement and the breath.
So if we're doing a movement with the breath,
let the breath guide the movement, rather
than for example, if we were -- we're going
to take a movement where we move the spine
with the breath.
This would be the movement of the inhale;
this would be the movement of the exhale.
You wouldn't want to move and then breathe
and then move and then remember to breathe.
There's really no difference between the movement
of the body and the movement of the breath.
So just work with those ideas.
It shouldn't be worse than if you weren't
doing it, and we're going to link the movement
to the body and the breath.
So let's start perched a little bit forward
on the chair.
If you're way slid back, come forward.
Let your feet be flat on the ground.
Anyone who wants to take their shoes off,
you're welcome to do that.
Legs comfortably apart.
And take a moment to lift your shoulders up
to your ears.
Some of you already have them there.
And then, drop them down.
And let's do that with an open-mouth exhalation.
Inhale -- lift your shoulders up to your ears.
Exhale -- relax and down.
One more time.
Let the shoulder blades drop even a little
more. [exhaling]
And let them kind of rest in this place with
the hands on the thighs or on the knees.
And, on your inhalation, draw the shoulders
back, lift the chest, look up a little bit.
And, as you exhale, put it in reverse -- draw
your belly in, drop your chin a little bit.
And continue with your breath -- inhale, lift
the chest; exhale, curve the back.
Keep it going at your pace.
And notice how the movement actually helps
extend the breath a little bit if you're patient.
When you round the back and pull the belly
in, it helps push the breath out.
When you lift the chest and relax the belly,
it creates a little more space for the breath
if you're patient.
Take maybe two more breaths in this way. [breathing]
And then, finish with the spine feeling pretty
neutral here.
Bring one hand to the belly -- maybe both
hands to the belly -- and either close your
eyes or just drop your gaze a little bit.
And now, connect to the sensation of the belly
moving when you breathe.
If you're patient and your pants aren't too
tight, you will probably find that your belly
expands when you breathe in and it draws in
when you breathe out.
And let's take a few more breaths, resting
the mind in the sensation of what expands
-- feeling the sensation of expansion as
you "breathe in" and the sensation of that
expansion dissolving as you "breathe out."
And then, open your eyes.
So with that, we did movement, breathing,
and meditation in just a couple of minutes.
That first movement helped release tension
in the belly and the back.
That helps release tension in the breath.
Next movement is going to help release tension
in the side of the body to also release tension
in the breath.
So, we're going to take the legs a little
wider apart if you've got the space for that.
And again, kind of scoot forward on your chair.
Let your left hand rest on your left thigh,
and you might even slide down to your elbow.
Notice how just that movement lengthened the
right side of your body.
That's already a stretch.
Bonus -- if you like -- inhale, take the right
arm up.
Notice that's a deeper stretch.
Are we in the zone now of "It still feels
better," or did that make it worse?
If it made it worse, you can lower the arm
down and relax your head in whatever direction
feels best.
If it feels better to have that right arm
reaching, do it with some intention.
Reach out through the fingers.
Feel the length in the side of your body,
and make a conscious choice to position your
head and neck in a way that feels sustainable.
If you had to be here for a little while,
what would be the position of least tension,
least likely to leave you feeling worse than
when we started?
And on your next inhale, come all the way
up and exhale -- release the arm down.
Take a simple breath in.
And, on your next exhalation, lean onto the
right arm.
Notice that subtle stretch, that subtle stretch.
And on an inhale, you can reach the left arm
up, and stay here for a few breaths.
Again, using the reach of the arm to improve
the sensation of opening.
And you might even have the idea of breathing
into the left side of your rib cage and waist.
If you just plant that idea, you may find
that, if you inhale deeply, you can increase
the stretch from the inside out.
There's a sensation of expanding underneath
the muscles that are stretching.
One last breath here.
And, on an inhale, come all the way up.
Exhale -- release that arm down.
You can walk your legs together.
And now, let's bring our hands to the side
of the body.
The ribs -- and whatever way is most comfortable
-- to find that part of your body.
And again, close your eyes or drop your gaze.
So it's easier for the mind to drop into the
breath.
And now, have the idea that, if you're patient,
the breath might expand the body where your
hands are resting.
Invite the possibility of some side-to-side
expansion when you breathe in without trying
to force it.
And let the mind rest in this feeling -- the
sensation.
As you do so, relaxing the forehead, relaxing
your eyes, relaxing the jaw if there's any
clenching, and then open the eyes.
Relax your arms down.
And then, the next movement or stretch is
going to help release tension in the neck
and the shoulder.
And you even have muscles in your neck and
in your shoulder that are involved in breathing.
When they're tense, they can turn your breath
into a kind of "up and down," shallow breath.
And by relaxing them, it can allow the natural
movement of the breath in a way that's not
quite so stressful and inefficient.
So for this -- very simple -- drop your left
ear to your left shoulder.
And notice if you are pulling your ear to
your shoulder with your neck muscles, that's
too much.
We don't need that much tension.
Just drop the head and let gravity hold you
in this posture.
Gravity can help you on the right side -- the
right arm.
By dropping the arm heavy alongside your outer
leg or even hooking on and holding onto the
chair if there's some place easy to do that.
And let the weight of the arm bone be heavy
and the weight of your head heavy.
And take another couple of breaths resting
in the sensation along the side of your neck,
the front of the shoulder and chest.
Smiling sometimes improves the sensation of
the stretch, because the muscles here connect
to the side of your face.
And on an inhale, come all the way up.
Before we do the other side, simply place
your left hand on the right side of your chest
underneath the collarbone -- underneath where
you were stretching.
And have the idea that there might be some
expansion of the breath under the hand here.
This is more likely to be a subtle expansion
of the breath.
And it doesn't involve lifting your shoulders
up to your ears.
If you close your eyes and drop your gaze,
see if there's a kind of massage that's happening
in this area of the easy, subtle expansion
of the lungs as you breathe in, and the release
of that expansion as you breathe out.
As if the lungs and the heart's gently expanding
-- gently swelling with the breath.
And open your eyes, relax your arms.
And let's even that off.
Take the second side, dropping your right
ear to your right shoulder.
And again, there's a real difference between
trying to pull the ear and shoulder together
with your neck muscles and shoulder muscles
-- versus, once you've tilted, let it go.
Let gravity drop the weight of the head.
And your left arm can hang down by your side,
or hook into the chair if that feels more
supportive.
And you can even experiment here with how
much the chin is "tucked down" versus "lifted
up."
It's a big difference.
And you can find the position -- the angle
of the chin -- that feels best to you to what's
needed in this moment.
And see, there's a way to enjoy the sensation.
We sometimes interpret stretch as pain, but
this is probably a safe movement for you and
maybe even a healing movement.
So, see if there's a way to interpret it in
that way -- enjoy how it feels. [pause]
And on an inhalation, bring the head back
up to center.
And then, take your right hand, rest it on
the left side of the chest.
And close your eyes, or drop your gaze.
And invite the possibility that this part
of the body will also have a nice rhythmic
expansion and release as you breathe.
This is one of my favorite meditations -- hands-on
breathing.
It gives the mind something to focus on; helps
relax the body.
Go ahead and open your eyes if they're closed.
And let's take one last stretch.
This will be for the front of the chest.
You can bring your hands to the back of your
chair.
And, you know, depending on your shoulders
and how tight your jacket is, reaching on
top of the chair might feel better or reaching
along the side of the chair might feel better,
and see which is true for you.
And then, just kind of hang the rib cage forward.
And the head can rest in a neutral position.
And you're not looking for the world's biggest
stretch here.
This is a shape change -- the spine is moving
into the body -- the chest is being opened
as the arms are pulled back, and whether you're
feeling a lot or whether you're feeling a
very subtle stretch, you can kind of trust
this process.
And see if you can feel the expansion of the
breath and your rib cage and chest.
And then, relax back to center.
And rest your hands over your heart, underneath
the collarbones.
And again, you can drop your gaze or close
your eyes.
And invite the possibility that this area
of the body will also expand gently when you
breathe in and sink as you breathe out. [pause]
And each time this area sinks -- each time
the heart sinks -- imagine any last bit of
stress or tension exiting the body.
And then, go ahead and open your eyes. Okay.
So, that was a little meditation, breathing,
movement all at once -- something you can
do at your office without people giving you
funny looks, like when I used to try doing
strange yoga poses in my office.
Unless you have a private office, and then,
anything goes.
Do they have private offices here?
See -- I don't know anything about Google.
Well, thank you very much for coming.
I think we are definitely out of time.
If anyone -- a couple of people had asked
me to sign books.
I'm more than happy to write a dedication
to you if you'd like.
And if you have any other one-on-one questions
you didn't want to ask for all of YouTube,
I'm here for that too.
We will turn off the camera and the mics.
[Applause]